-Welcome, everybody!
Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
Thank you for watching.
[ Applause ]
Well, guys, it is the last night
of Donald Trump's presidency.
And...
[ Band plays,
cheers and applause ]
I don't know what
tomorrow's gonna feel like.
Probably like that moment
when they pull the nasal swab
out of your nose.
[ Laughter ]
At least Trump
is leaving on top.
I mean, Washington D.C. has
never looked more beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, that has nothing to do
with the riots.
Those are just some of Melania's
old Christmas decorations.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, one more night.
For most Americans, it feels
like the night of Thanksgiving
when you're just staring at
your aunt and uncle thinking,
"Go home."
I think everyone is ready
for Trump to move on.
This afternoon, even
the Lincoln Memorial stood up
and helped Trump pack.
He's like, "I got it, I got it."
Some people are sad
to see Trump go.
Earlier today, the movers
shook his hand and said,
"We've never moved so many
people out of their offices
in four years.
You put our kids
through college.
Thank you."
It was a touching scene
at the White House tonight,
especially when Trump's four
remaining staffers toasted him
by raising a glass of bleach.
I thought that was sweet.
Today, all of
the White House staffers
are signing
each other's yearbooks
with things like,
"Keep in touch,"
"Friends for life," and,
"I won't testify against you
if you don't testify
against me."
Well, tomorrow morning,
Trump's holding a farewell event
at Joint Base Andrews.
I heard that
everyone who's invited
has to be there by 7:15 a.m.,
and they can each bring along
five people.
You know they're having trouble
filling seats
when they offer everyone
a plus-five.
Never heard of a plus-five.
"You can come if you want.
You can you bring 30 people."
But it sounds like
a great party.
I mean, guests have to arrive
by 7:15 in the morning
on a Wednesday
in the middle of January
during a pandemic.
Even Craigslist actors
were like, "Pass."
And this is true.
The guest list is so thin,
even Anthony Scaramucci
got an invite.
You know your party
is struggling
when it's half family and half
staff you fired four years ago.
But today, Trump released
a pre-recorded farewell address
from the White House, and
here are some of the highlights.
-Now as I prepare
to hand power over
to a new administration
at noon on Wednesday,
I want you to know that
the movement we started
is only just beginning.
We did what we came here to do
and so much more.
The world respects us again.
Please don't lose that respect.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Trump said, "We did
what we came here to do."
It's true. I remember
his big campaign promise
was, "Build part of a wall
and pay for it ourselves."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump also said,
"The world respects us again."
When he heard that,
Vladimir Putin was like,
"Yes, yes, is always good
to end with joke."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"Classic, Buddy. [ Laughs ]"
But today wasn't all bad.
There was actually some nice
news for Trump. Listen to this.
-President Trump's youngest
daughter has a big announcement.
Tiffany Trump
is getting married.
The 27-year-old
took to Instagram
to announce her happy news.
-Trump was so sweet.
He was like, "This week
isn't about you, Tiffany!"
[ Laughter ]
Asked what
she's most excited for,
Tiffany was like,
"Changing last names."
Some entertainment news.
Last night was an all-new
episode of "The Bachelor,"
and Serena had a one-on-one date
with Matt.
And the date was going well
until an unexpected visitor
showed up.
Watch this.
-The feelings that
I'm already having for you,
like, throughout this experience
is like,
they're real.
♪♪
[ Donkey brays ]
[ Laughter ]
-All that was missing
was a graphic that said,
"Donkey, age 7,
social media influencer."
Yep, now along with herpes,
"The Bachelor" has to worry
about foot-and-mouth disease.
Hey, check this out.
I saw that Nissan has designed
a new concept van
intended to serve as a mobile
office for remote workers.
Take a look at this.
Yeah. And this is cool.
It comes with a bumper sticker
that says,
"I didn't get custody."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Nissan
will release the car
right after everyone
is vaccinated
and returns to the office.
We have a great show.
give it up for The Roots
everybody.